everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I have a lot
of stuff to talk about we probably won't
be doing that much coding so I hope
that's alright but I want to give you a
little recap of how things were at
November and then we have a lot of stuff
coming up this month and in January so I
want to give you all an overview of all
the different things that we'll be
working on and then if you'd like to
look you know help work on some of those
things that'd be great I'll probably
make repos for everything that I talked
about today soon if there aren't arty
repos for them and then we can you know
start opening issues and pull requests
some of these projects gonna be really
fun technologies we haven't worked with
before so I'm hoping that I'm hoping
that this will be exciting to hear all
this news and it'll make up for the lack
of of code so first of all let me talk
about November sorry
ok there we go the analytics on YouTube
were saying that no one was watching for
a long time
just checking so November was really
really fun and I I talked about my
experience with with this stream with
with live coding and I got it just so
many positive comments afterwards it was
amazing it went you know better than I
could have hoped for so the video of my
talk is on my youtube channel so it's
the first video on the channel right now
I can paste in a link for you all let me
do that now and that way you can check
it out if you want maybe I'll put a link
in the description for those of you who
are watching the recording
hopefully I remember to do that and
we'll put it in I don't always remember
to put in the links when I say I'm going
to
all right so here's the link now in the
live chat and of course you're probably
not gonna want to watch it right now if
you miss the stream but okay cool it
looks like Brooke I already watched it
do you like the humble joke crew I yeah
I thought it was cool I thought it was
funny
I'm drinking the worst coffee I've ever
had in my life right now I don't know
how long had been sitting in the pot
right because I was gone in Nashville
for the last three days so it's entirely
possible that coffees been sitting there
for more than a day
I just warm it up with a microwave for a
long time hoping to kill any bacteria
and it's really bad but I didn't have
time to actually make fresh coffee cuz
the stream is starting so alright so let
me talk a little bit about the cool
things at November and and then we'll
get to the project so if anybody happens
to be watching the stream and you were
at November say hi in the live chat if
you can and that'd be really cool so
just some of the highlights and if
anybody's watching and your speaker or I
talk to you in November and I forget to
bring up bring you up as one of the
highlights I apologize but it's hard to
remember things being on the spot live
so poofing Gabrielle from Microsoft she
did a node robotics workshop that was
amazing we actually built a node bot
that was a little car that you could
control with node from your keyboard so
the code was literally like you know
when you press the right arrow key then
the node bot will go right so it was
controlling
the wheels based on like we had a little
battery pack and this little thing
called a photon which is kind of like an
artery no I mean it was really cool a
little motor so cool so then I actually
got to keep this stuff for the node but
so I think I took it apart to bring it
home
and I think I'm gonna make it with my
kids so that was really kind of cool
highlight don't know that I'll use it
for my job here but it was it was fun to
see how that works and maybe I'll find
some some practical use for it around
here also there was a great talk about
one of the keynotes from BAM Ben Oleg
Badu gave a talk on why Eventbrite
switched to react so he wrote this
really long like 19 page paper
convincing everyone at Eventbrite why
react was the way to go and they were
switching from backbone and there were a
lot of cool things in there that I had
never considered that was a good reason
to go with react so I really like that
we think what else there is a cool
presentation from someone at github
her name was Shelly so Shelly from
github gave a presentation on
async/await
which was really cool because we've
started using that in some of our
projects and it was cool to learn about
she basically went through the history
of how you do things like that so from
callbacks to promises talked a little
bit about generators and then on to
async/await so it gave me like a nice
overview of how that sort of thing has
been handled in JavaScript so very
useful and I know I'm forgetting so many
other things but I mean really the
biggest highlight was meeting so many
developers from all over really all over
the United States from so many different
companies from big companies like
Microsoft
I actually met and got to talk to Murray
for Microsoft who works on the
office was that the outlook app she
builds microservices for the outlook app
which is cool although later like local
small companies that were local to
Nashville let's talk from you know devs
from they're just really cool I got to
talk to some people from Heroku and net
liffe I and that's actually gonna I'm
gonna bring that up later when we talk
about our projects because I think we're
gonna do some stuff with metal thigh and
possibly with Heroku as well so anyway
if anybody from November happens to be
watching now or later on you watch
you're recording you all are awesome
especially anybody who I talked to
you're awesome I enjoy so much you know
meeting everyone and then talking
everybody was just so nice and so
hopefully some of those people from
November will start watching the stream
occasionally and we can keep in touch
alright so let me go check the lights
act quickly to see if there's any
November related questions and then
we'll move on also I guess one other
thing the the free stuff at November was
awesome I got cool t-shirts I'm wearing
I don't know how I can show you I'm not
I'm not gonna try to show you but I'm
wearing Heroku socks right now which
look really cool I've got a bunch of
stickers free time on Heroku so 500 free
Dino hours on Heroku I did get a cool
fidget spinner from oh no it doesn't say
the the company name I'm sorry I really
wanted to give him a shout-out but it
doesn't say the name I got a cool water
bottle that is branded for November
so anyway highly recommend going to
November if you can for 2018 I'll try to
go back there if I can it was really
cool maybe they want me to speak again I
don't know I have to come up with
something different to talk about so
so we said let's see how Brett said
Jessie you deserve a fresh cup every day
a fresh cup of coffee look thanks for
that
Oh
cooler John says I'm a natural at
talking yeah that's yeah it seems like I
have the talking down I just need to
talk less in code and more right that's
the I said every word says a street
fighter motorcycles says I look at the
screen I have a notification from you I
push the button you're talking about
this thing drinking bad coffee what are
you talking about I'm worried now my
blood pressure is up I got a hard thing
please I need to know if the coffee is
good I'm worried the coffee is terrible
that's what I get for trying to warm up
old coffee you have no idea how old it
is
street count says tell us about tell
something about November I'm new to your
channel oh yeah if you're not I keep
saying November I didn't explain
anything about what it was it's a
JavaScript conference specifically
geared around node but there are a lot
of talks about front-end stuff as well
no just being JavaScript that can run on
the on the server so really good
conference it was in Nashville Tennessee
a lot of the talks were about react or
like somewhat react related stuff like
graph QL which is frequently used with
react but then there was other stuff
like the node bot thing that had nothing
to do with react just you know reacts
it's really popular now so anyway so I
got a lot from it because we work with
react and so there are a lot of things
you know that I can apply now to our
projects all right though I guess so
well from Argentina hey how's it going
also from New York great and actually I
met the
people of November from the Dominican
Republic which is awesome because I've
never met anyone from the Dominican
Republic before and then now within like
two days I met three people and they are
all really really nice awesome people so
if anybody's from the Dominican Republic
watching say hi and let's see
Oso from Brazil from Bosnia awesome
yeah people from all over I love it okay
so now let me move into some of our
projects I'm gonna throw a lot of stuff
at you all cool we got someone from
Dominican Republic great the angel
Eduardo Rodriguez Bailey's awesome hey
I'm from Dominican Republic - all right
cool got two people from Dominican
Republic here all right we have some
from India I always have people from
India India is well represented I think
in the in the streams that's awesome and
I always am like amazed that you all in
India stay up so late to watch this and
thanks thank you for that that's like
it's amazing to me that that you are
willing to stay up Bukenya awesome if
someone from Kenya all right so I'm
gonna throw a lot at you with these
projects now so I'm not gonna go
in-depth into any one of them because I
want to make sure I get them all in and
then if there's questions you have about
any of the projects let me know and then
I'll talk more about the projects that
you are more interested in and I'll just
kind of go quickly through the stuff
that maybe it's not so interesting to
you let's see from the Ukraine we have
Algeria Norway awesome
yeah urine from from Norway I remember
thank you though for reminding me cool
because I remember I had trouble
pronouncing that at one time so
okay so let's talk about let's talk
first about the project we've been
working on right because I did say that
this was still part of Project five so I
want to make sure we talk about project
five so it's not misleading so that's
this main website that we've been
building we started in Gatsby and then
we switch to react but we kept our
gatsby branch open so here's what I'm
thinking all right
I had emerged some pull requests in so
thank you for everybody for the pull
request and I'll maybe I'll go over that
and at some point today or tomorrow we
had a cup at least one person it was the
first pull request I think so
congratulations on that but I talked to
some people who know a lot more about
Gatsby than I do and I think that it
will be very doable to do this site and
Gatsby before I was kind of not sure
about it you know
partly because I'd never used Gatsby
before so I I really just have no idea
no experience as to whether or not what
we wanted to accomplish would be best
accomplished with Gatsby and I think
that it we can and I think it may end up
being faster so here's what I'd like to
do I'd like to build out the sites both
sites the next version and the Gatsby
version just a little bit more to the
point where we're actually pulling some
data from a like a test WordPress
installation we'll try to pull it with
graph QL and I'd like to set up both of
them in a production environment and
then test the speed and potentially to
even test like the load on servers if we
can from what I've heard at November
Gatsby should be faster
if we set it up the way that I was I was
talking about so I think I know this is
crazy to keep trying to develop these
well you know we're we're not that far
into the development of this site so I
don't know let me know what you all
think about it but it just seems like it
seems like the speed advantage is going
to be significant
so in particular I do I want to thank
Brian Douglas from net liffe I so I you
know I doubt who ever watched this or
anything but I just want to thank him
for taking the time to go through
explaining a lot about how Gatsby and
net liffe I handle sites like this like
where we're pulling data from the API
and how the rebuilds work and and all
that so so that is the big the big kind
of changed for this project that will
that will do it will try to do so if
anybody is more interested in working
with Gatsby than you are with necks feel
free to start working on the branch what
I'd like to do is keep them as similar
as possible so in terms of UI it's
they're gonna be identical which should
make it a little bit easier you know all
the us stuff can pretty much just be
copied and then the only things that are
really changed is kind of our server
setup right because the routing with
Gatsby was similar right it was just the
stuff that's in the pages file I believe
the pages folder I mean so anyway we'll
have to take a closer look at that and
work on it but I have a much at least I
think I have a much better understanding
of how that would actually work so
anyway that's big change number one
we're gonna most likely go back and be
doing some updates on our very first
project that we did
the stream that catechetical Institute
website that we built with next
WordPress the wordpress api we did
server-side rendering a lot of caching
in there we're doing load balancing on
that so if you weren't with us during
that project you know check out the repo
for it if you go to the rebuild with all
the other projects I think it's called
CI react so I'm gonna probably open up
some issues in that repository for the
new things but just to give you a heads
up I'm gonna have a meeting I think next
week or the week after I can't remember
the date with the people who are in
charge of that that project the
catechetical Institute some of the
things that are requested are basically
a space kind of above the forum on the
home page for new like news and and
stuff so that they can kind of pin it to
the top all this new stuff so we already
have that section at the bottom so
there's gonna have to be some discussion
on what this is going to look like since
we already have a section that does
exactly that could could we just move
the section up and maybe redesign it so
that it's not quite as big I don't know
we'll have to discuss it but if you all
have any suggestions for that let me
know and then I can bring it up in the
meeting or also we're gonna add some new
sections that will basically be
identical to some existing sections so
that's not really even worth discussing
they'd like to maybe update that find a
nearby event section that we already had
the geolocation in but we just need to
build out the UI so that it's obvious
that you can use the geo location so we
had never finished finished that before
so we'll get to that so if anybody has
any ideas for you know kind of an
intuitive way to basically for a user to
know that these fields are clickable and
they can sort by them
in a way that looks nice you know mobile
desktop and it's pretty obvious and fits
with the overall material design scheme
and the particular color scheme for that
site let's see oh we're gonna have to do
some forms most likely so it's not like
we haven't done anything like this
before but we'd currently don't have any
forms on that site so we're gonna have
probably two forms and so it's not gonna
be a big deal I don't think we need file
uploads at all so it's going to be
pretty basic but you know we'll need
some form elements we need some the word
just slipped my mind
when you check form validation that's it
so we need some form validation let's
see okay they're not happy with the font
size so they think the font size is too
large so we'll see we'll see I'm more
likely I like to have a larger font for
readability so I'll have to let you know
how that goes that will be hard to
change though and good news is that
resource page that we spent so much time
building they love the resource page and
they thanked us they thanked me for all
the hard work but I know that you all
did a lot of the work too so I'm gonna
extend that thanks to you all for that
and we may end up adding an entirely new
page to the site that would be a place
to submit advice and then also have that
advice displayed for everyone so that's
a possibility that's listed as something
that would come in the future that we
might not have to work on you know this
month or even next month so I'm gonna
check the live chat see if there's any
questions about some of the updates that
I just talked about before I move on
and let me know - if you if you'd like
to see like something else on the screen
besides me I can switch back to the view
where you see the code I don't have a
lot of good to show you right now but
I'm happy to switch it if you if you
like okay okay the wall says so are your
past projects on myrn stack what is that
so mine is what like it helped me out on
mine I can't remember what the M is is
the M [ __ ] is it [ __ ] X express reacts
node engine X okay so they miss [ __ ]
well yeah what we're somewhat on the
moon stack we haven't really used [ __ ]
very much did we use I think one of the
projects that we haven't launched yet
uses [ __ ] that bulletin project we have
some updates for that too so we'll get
to that I hope I don't forget because
those are really exciting but basically
all our projects we've used react if we
need to do stuff like custom server
stuff we're also doing some some things
with with express obviously node we've
used yes so we have the urn of the Maron
stack we have the ER n um that's that's
what yeah so thank thanks for the in
Elijah thank you for letting me know
what with the everything in Marin was so
I had I had some of it right I forgot
about the [ __ ] yeah so basically we
have everything except them although all
right let's see
a lot of people saying hello there's
somebody from Birmingham UK there's a
Birmingham in the United States too so
makes me want to specify from Romania
but living in Birmingham awesome Albania
cool oh there's a new react update so
John Hanson mentioned react update 16.2
no more div around news or using an
array of components with named keys and
commas react fragment is here awesome
also check that out maybe if if possible
I'll try to use that feature in an
upcoming stream I think that'd be really
cool to you know try it out live as soon
as we can
cool Jordan says hey from Ann Arbor
Michigan awesome alright let me move on
to I think the most exciting things that
we're going to work on so let me let me
set up this scenario for you all I took
so that you all know why I think we
should do this so as some of you may
know recall I try my best to not
complain on the stream but you may have
heard me complain about the amount of
support I have to provide for things
like the bulletin or the Resource Center
for the bulletin in particular the login
process people just almost always the
problem is old browsers but occasionally
there's some weird things with emails
not being sent it's not really from our
end the emails do get sent from ioan
they just don't get picked up by they
get blocked basically I don't even want
to say block because I don't even get a
message that they're blocked they just
get lost somewhere along the way I don't
know why but anyway we have that problem
and then in the Resource Center we have
the problem with older browsers not
accepting the forms being submitted so
right now we have a disclaimer on our
one or
forms that it does not work with older
browsers but I think I figured out a way
where we could just totally avoid all of
that browser compatibility stuff and I
was inspired to do this when I was
talking with Shelley from github
I cannot remember her last name so sorry
but Shelley from github was a speaker at
November works on the electron team so
if you're not familiar with electron
it's a way to build desktop apps for
Windows and Mac I think also also Linux
I'm pretty sure that it works for Linux
too but you can build that in JavaScript
HTML and CSS and it will run as a
desktop app so some examples of this are
Adam Visual Studio code slack
maybe Spotify I can't remember Spotify
the desktop app runs on that or not but
for sure the first three that I said so
I think we should make the bulletin and
the the Resource Center desktop apps and
mobile apps so we're going to be using
react native for mobile and then is
there a name for making electron apps
with react does it have a special name
or we just is it just called electron
and we'll just use react I don't know if
there's a special name let me know but I
think that'll be so cool because we've
never done anything with electron before
and we've just kind of briefly looked at
one of my projects that I did with react
native but I was just kind of showing
you all how you know kind of final
result we didn't really work on it
together so these are going to be like
side projects that will do in parallel
so I'll create repos for them I'll set
up like the boilerplate so you
use create react native app and get it
started just to set up the repo and then
I'm gonna need to do my research on
electron because I've never done
anything with electron so whatever is
the easiest way to just get something
started will do that and then the
process will simply be taking what we
already have for those projects so the
resource center is already live and it's
at a completed stage we will port those
over to react native and to electron and
then before the bulletin there's a
little bit more we have to do for the
bulletin to get it to a completed stage
but we'll also have repose open for
those so that when I have time I'll work
on it when I can but as you all may know
my number one priority now is that main
website that we're working on at project
five so as I can I'll work on them but
if any of you are really interested in
learning more about react native or
electron and you're kind of looking for
a project then you know go ahead with
this I'll try to do my best to keep up
with pull requests and open up issues
but the cool thing is you already know
exactly what's expected from this
because you can just check out what
we've done on the just normal react
versions of both of these so yes so and
these are some things that they don't
need to be done there's no due date on
these this is just kind of my idea I ran
it by my boss this morning and he
thought it was a great idea so you know
I we're gonna do them and it'll happen
sometime but there's no due date on
these so we'll just work when we can I
think I think that's all the only other
thing that I want everybody to still
keep in mind is I'm looking for a good
JavaScript CMS that is as easy for a
user to work with as WordPress in terms
of being able to upload
what I don't want is I know there are
some CMS's out there that are like you
you pay for like monthly I don't want
something like that I want something
that is preferably entirely open source
and can be self hosted just like you
know WordPress can be self hosted but I
love for it to be JavaScript so we don't
have to mess with any PHP I mean
obviously it needs to be very easily you
know compatible with graph QL net Liffe
I has a CMS that I haven't looked into
it all I just heard about I don't think
that it will work for our use case but
you know we we don't need to decide on
that yet so I'm still kind of testing
things out if we need to to get some
data just to test things we'll use
WordPress with graph QL and that'll be
fine because we could always plug in a
different source of data later on all
right I think that's all that I had in
terms of new announcements if I think of
something I'll let you know but I will
so hey I just got all these messages
so just distracting nave in a second
the really cool thing about the November
conference as well is I made so many met
so many new people and then the fact
that you can just add people on Twitter
right away is great because then I can
contact I love that we're not like
exchanging business cards anymore right
like it's just like okay what's your
what's your Twitter name you know right
there and now we can you know
communicate like that anyway let me
check the live chat quickly before we
move on to something so I can answer any
questions
streetfighter says just as the coffee
gotten any better with age no it's as if
not I suggest instant coffee sticks I
recommend them personally they are
amazing an instant coffee stick would be
an improvement on what I have right now
it definitely keeps me awake just from
like the flavor in my mouth it's just
awful I don't know why I keep drinking
it I need to put it far away from me so
I don't drink it anymore
let's see
okay so electron does work on all
platforms thanks so angel I'm do you
pronounce your name angel or some other
I mean because you're from Dominican
Republic so I'm assuming that's not how
you pronounce it let me know how you
pronounce it I'm not gonna try to guess
and mess it up I want to know how you
pronounce it so I can I can get it right
world boss asked if I'm a freelancer I
am NOT a freelancer I was a freelancer
for three years but now I am employed
full-time as a front-end developer I do
all of some freelance work on the side
still I'm currently not I shall I take
that back I'm currently doing like very
minimal freelance work I have someone
who's how like a friend of the family
and I keep their WordPress blog up to
date I upload some post form twice a
month
and twice a month ago and an update
plugins so it's really minimal I mean
literally I make $15 a month off of them
it's like super minimal it's insane
because I spend like way less than an
hour a month on that site and I gave
them a very good price because because
of the connection the family connection
anyway I am interested in doing
freelance work so I don't want to be
always doing something because it's hard
on my family but if anybody ever has any
projects and you know you'd like some
help with them I'm open to that I'm
really picky about little projects I do
so I'm not gonna guarantee that I will
say yes to doing that but I I do like if
it's a technology that I'm interested in
that sounds fun then and and potentially
if the if the price is right as well
then I'm definitely interested in in
doing that let's see of a few other
questions John Hanson says Jesse I
wonder if some of the email delivery
issue comes from DKIM and SPF pass in
the header of the message this is a
server-side setting and needs to be in
place from the web hosting servers all
right I honestly have I don't know
anything about those issues I've never
heard about that before so you may be
right but I don't even know how to check
that so so anyway John if I don't if you
have more info about that can give me
some more direction I can try to check
into it I assume that it was a problem
with the university's email servers
since basically I can trace it through
send grid and send grid says that it's
delivered but they still don't see it
and I know other people have had similar
issues with other things other than send
grid I'm hoping so at the end of the
month and we're going to switch over to
use
instead of GroupWise we're gonna use
outlook I was hoping that with that
switch it might help things that's why I
haven't really been like digging too far
into it because I thought it may end up
being a waste but I'm I I don't know
that much about email servers and things
like that so I'm definitely open to any
advice you all have
okay so the Spanish pronunciation of
Angel is different so what would you say
so is it like I'm Hell or something like
that I don't know all right you know
what let's look this up right now
all right so I got it
oh man this is killing me I have to
watch a commercial to watch a
five-second video on how to pronounce it
uncle I'm who okay according to YouTube
that's it all right that's cool okay so
on Hill says yes that's good all right
awesome
I think it's important to do my best to
pronounce your names correctly so anyway
all right
Brett says possibly starting a job right
next to Blue Bottle coffee in Oakland
California have you tried Blue Bottle I
have not tried a Blue Bottle is it
really good I'm not sure if I can get
Blue Bottle coffee out here in eastern
Ohio oh cool a street fighter says
Shelly from github is an amazing person
I've never met her but I've listened to
people who have yeah like I only talked
with her we were both in the speaker's
lounge like prepping for our speeches
our talks at the same time so just kind
of like you know occasionally talking
but yeah and she seemed really amazing I
mean and she's not even out of college
yet and she's already working for github
and and doing cool work with electron a
lot of C++ work yeah really cool so I
think I mean she's gonna be like I think
an amazing programmer already right you
know being so young and already you're
doing such great work so yeah so it was
really cool to get to meet her all right
Bret says so we are swapping necks js4
gassy gas beyond fu s marcom no not on
fu s mmm let me you know let me switch
my screen and bring up the repo just so
that we're 100% on the same page I
should have done this right off the bat
when we were looking at this we have
summer homes Franciscan react yeah this
is it Franciscan reacts okay
so this this repo so the it is in the fu
s Markham organization and then the
Franciscan react site so we have
branches right now so we have a gas B
branch and we have our master branch we
also had an ex branch but that was
merged into master and it's no longer
being updated so the master right now is
next and then we have that Gatsby branch
what I'd like to do is put a say I want
to pull in data into the master so that
we can run a test of being able to pull
in data from graph QL from the probably
WordPress server-side rendering that and
then serving that and then doing the
same thing with Gatsby but instead of
server-side rendering it will build a
static site and then push that to the
client so I'd like to get them to the
same point with just like minimal UI and
bringing in the same data and then just
do some testing on it to see like which
one's easier to deploy and work with
which one is faster I think it would be
cool
I know there's articles and people have
already done stuff like this but I think
it would be really cool to do it live on
the stream I don't know I think there's
value in that if he has if you all think
that that's kind of a waste of time let
me know but sometimes it's just cool to
you know try it and see the results
being able to like tweak things on our
own you know and and see how it changes
the the load times and things also you
know being able to see like what's the
size of the files that get sent to the
client you know will one give us you
know less that needs to be sent because
that's you know ideal anyway so that's
the plan and while I'm in here on github
I'll just so that we're clear on the
other things let me make this bigger
okay so
we're going to do this resource center
here the resource center repo we're
going to make another repo that'll
probably be your resource center react
native and then we'll have a resource
center electron and we'll build it out
react native build it out an electron I
do want to make sure when we build out
with react native we use the proper
components so that it will work on iOS
and Android if you've never used react
native that might be confusing but there
are some components that only work on
Android so we don't want to use those if
we do use those we definitely want to
have a check first like a ternary and if
statement saying you know if it's not
iOS then use this so I'm okay with that
as long as we account for that so I mean
I'll talk about it more when we actually
make those repos and everything but just
keep that in mind and then on this
bulletin react which isn't finished yet
we're going to also have an electron
version of this that will be a separate
repo and a react native version that'll
be a separate repo and again if you
weren't here when I discuss this the
reason behind this is that I'm having a
lot of trouble with people with really
old browsers trying to view this and
it's it's causing me a lot of time to
have to handle that kind of thing and
it's so I usually the complaint comes in
to someone else in my department they
have to handle it then I have to handle
it and then what I usually have to do is
go over check it out because often the
times they don't know the browser they
have and then I don't have the the
access to be able to update their
browser I need an admin password for
that and I don't have like kind of the
universal admin password so then I have
to get in contact with somebody from the
IT department and then hope that they
get over there and upgrade everything
correctly so you can see it for each
time that happens it takes a lot of time
out so the solution I'm thinking is
have electron which if they're using
electron right then they're
automatically getting a version of
chrome version of chromium that will
work so they won't realize it but
they're essentially downloading the
browser that they need to run it
properly
so I and I believe I need to test this
out on Windows but on a Mac even if you
don't have an admin password you can
still download electron apps and they
work so I had done that before
on a Mac that I didn't have an admin
password for so assuming that it also
works with Windows then that would be
really great
so anyway also I think it would just be
really cool and a great experience for
for me and for all of you to be able to
build iOS app an Android app and a
desktop app that'll work cross-platform
to build all that together I think it'll
be some great skills that can be in your
portfolio and some great skills you know
be able to take like our starting point
and then you all can use that and modify
it to make your own apps or your own you
know desktop apps with electron I just I
think it'd be really fun
okay john hanson talking again about the
email thing says once you look up these
two items dkim and SPF and get them set
it can mean a difference of mail taking
hours days not at all versus the mail
going through in seconds contact the web
hosting service okay cool I'll have to
I'll probably have to talk to the IT
department then I'll look it up though
because I'm not I'm still not understand
sure whether that be something on the
email sending or the receiving side so I
will have to look that up I'm still
hopeful that maybe it'll be fixed when
we switch to Outlook okay cool on Hill
says I think if we have time to do all
that that test the performance it'll be
good and we will learn more on the run
yeah you know what that's a good point
if we have time to do that if you
remember we still need to have this done
by mid-february preferably early
February so we can have more time for
testing and this thing needs to launch
by the end of February so you're right
we need to keep that in mind
so this testing needs to happen soon
like let's try to get both of the
branches to the point where we can get a
decent test within the next week and
then we'll make our decision and there's
no more second guessing and it's me
that's doing all the second-guessing so
I'm gonna promise to no more
second-guessing whatever we pick at that
point we're gonna stick with it and
we're not gonna switch at least not for
months and months so that'll be the goal
before the end of next week we'll make a
final decision based on our testing Matt
Robin said didn't know you were gonna be
in my neck of the woods also matter you
from around Nashville then if so yeah I
wish I wish we could have connected I
actually had very little time the one
thing about November that was good or
bad
on how you look at it is it was just
packed with stuff breakfast for the
conference started at 8:00 a.m. and then
the keynotes were over at 6:00 p.m. and
then after that every single night there
was some type of event so you know
really you could go from 8 a.m. to 8
p.m. or later pretty much every day of
the conference so it was packed with
stuff I had hoped to get some pool
requests merged and things at the
conference but I had no time when I did
have any time I was like taking a nap
because it was it was exhausting but
good it was good exhausting all right
let's see I am on time 250 let's see ok
so I think that's all I wanted to say in
terms of updates
just checking briefly yeah that's it in
terms of the update so we got a lot of
stuff kind of planned out and I guess we
could I'd say you what we still have
we've only been streaming for less than
an hour so I usually go longer than this
let's do one Pomodoro cycle of setting
up the react native repo for let's say
let's do into the Resource Center since
the Resource Center is already finished
so I'm going to go through the setup
process we're going to use create react
native app and then we'll set up the
repo and then that way we'll have at
least one of the repos that we need to
set up so one out of the four new ones
that we're going to have I don't think
we've yeah we've definitely not done
this on a stream so if you've never used
react native before hopefully this will
be beneficial to you and where's my
Pomodoro
have it somewhere all right this uses
Pomodoro clock and let me pull over my
my terminal
okay
let me make this big enough so that you
all can see it okay so first thing I'm
gonna do is CD in my Mac into my
projects folder and so here's what I'm
gonna do I will be going to the create
react native app github page and
following the instructions for that and
you all can follow along if you want if
you just search for create Rack native
app for me on google the very first
result that came up was the github page
so we're gonna install that globally I'm
just gonna copy over what's on there
just to save time
so it's install
is that is it over already that was like
super fast amazing all right cool all
right so I'm in the projects folder and
I'm going to say create Rack native app
and then we're going to give it a name
so this is a resource center so let's
call it or I'm gonna call it R C RC
native
I read somewhere that there was some
weird issue where you can't use camel
case or hyphens I can't remember exactly
what issue was but that's why I'm gonna
make it like this which is a little
weird but just so that we don't run into
that issue that's that's why I'm doing
this every time I've ever used this
which was once I just had one word and
it was all lowercase so I've never dealt
with that issue so what this is going to
do is give us kind of a starting point
for react native app and when it goes
when it's all done we'll have a new
folder named RC native that we'll be
able to go into and we should be able to
see basically it'll be a working app
you see while it's going through this
thing I'm gonna check the live chat
John Hanson says does this mean I'm
personally soon going to be building a
react native app I'm just getting used
to create react app blaming all of it on
you that's a yeah yeah we're gonna do
react native don't worry if you are
intimidated that's exactly how I felt
before I made my first one it's so much
easier than than you might think
all right so you're in starts and the
expo alright so let's see D arcy native
which it gives you nice instructions
right there and then let's let's yarn
start I don't know if I have everything
I need on this computer I do like my
laptop I thought I'd downloaded
everything I need we'll see I do have so
on your phones you will need to download
if you want to work on this an app
called Expo that's e xp0 so you can see
are talking about Expo here and that'll
allow you to preview what's going on
directly on your phone which is awesome
and so I'm gonna go here in my search
bar and in Expo now I could potentially
think if this always runs I don't
remember if this always runs over Wi-Fi
or if you can plug in your phone and
have it run like that but this should
work as long as I'm on the same network
which we double check that I am on the
same network I am cool
let's see let me open up Expo and maybe
I'll make my screen bigger just to show
you all you can also use the emulator so
let me open up the iOS emulator so you
can see it there
oh I could just scan the QR code with my
thinking similar kismet problem alright
so it looks like I could not open it Q
let me display that QR code again it's
way too big I need to make this smaller
so I can see it okay cool it work now
yeah so let me make my screen my camera
bigger so you can see some of this it's
alright I'll let you see it when it
actually gets finished it does take a
minute
oh shoot what happened sorry Chad scan
the scene
alright almost done not if I was
thinking properly I would have put up I
would have used visors as you can see
this on the screen but I wasn't planning
on doing this Oh what the heck happen
dismiss
come on
if you shake it you can reload so you
can see I shook it and hit reload mmm
unidentified it's not an object
I already made a version major all right
I'm not exactly sure I'm not sure what
the problem is I'm currently getting an
error message and the glares you
probably can't see cuz of the glare so
that's odd I've never gotten an error
message right away what I do want to do
though is duplicate this tab quickly and
then open up Adam just to show you the
file structure
all right see we have all our node
modules which is always a lot and CRF
jeaious there we go okay so check this
out this looks almost exactly like the
regular react that we're used to using
I'm still on me sorry there you go check
this out look at this we're importing
react to react and then we're importing
a couple of components from react native
right export default class right this is
all familiar and then we're rendering
return we have a view which when you see
view and react native think div okay and
then when you see text instead of P tags
or even H tags we have our text tags so
and look at our our style sheet so we
have our Styles here we're using flexbox
we have a background color right so
without I know I can't get this to show
up but we already know exactly what this
is gonna look like right we have our
container that's gonna have a white
background we're using flex all right
it's going to take up the full screen
and we're gonna Center it so the items
will be centered both vertically and
horizontally and all we're gonna have
our three lines of text and it's gonna
say this right just like we have in
there so so easy we can check out our
package.json and see it's just simple
now of course this is the create react
native app right if we ejected it would
be way more complicated but for now this
is what we have we run start when we
were when we're in development mode and
I believe if we want to make an Android
app we type Android it and it creates
all the files we need and then if we
want to do with iOS this is we just say
by iOS so NPM star
yes or I'm sorry npm run iOS or we could
just do your an iOS yeah super easy and
that's it and this is I still I have no
idea what the issue is with the with the
air that I'm getting but maybe I'll just
I'll try one more time to restart this
and then if it still doesn't work
then I'm not gonna try it again
all right so in the live side
Blake got in here that is cruel like no
actually Blake this is an electron right
now this is react native so we will be
working with electron in the future but
right now I was trying to set up react
native but I keep getting an error
saying undefined it's not an object
evaluating negative version major major
and node modules directory photos my
friends no man yeah don't know why this
is not working
see you Maya don't you start
see
is my npm version
okay I have the the right version that
should work ensue
I do let me double-check I did check on
the network so on Hill says check the
network yeah it is the the correct
network
mmm the
it's already up to date okay
all right let me I just totally turned
off that instance of the app that I was
trying to run an expo and I restarted
the server and now I'm going to try to
open it again let's see if something
happened maybe I'm like gonna flush out
yeah it worked awesome okay I don't know
what happened at first but once I I
turned it off and turned it back on and
then that fixed it so let me show you I
know it's gonna be hard to see and like
again I'm sorry I didn't set it up so I
could show it on my screen but here's
our trying to get out of the glare you
can probably maybe barely see it
depending on what your screen resolution
is but there's the text that we had open
up app it's all backwards for me who's
trying to look ahead open up app das to
start working on your app so there we go
so essentially in just a few minutes it
would have been shorter if I would have
just restarted it right off the bat and
got it working but in just a few minutes
we actually have an Android app that
works now we didn't bundle this all in
the correct file format or anything like
that so I mean I guess technically it's
not exactly like an Android app but you
know we have it running via Expo on an
Android phone right now and if I had an
iOS device it would I could do the same
thing so last thing I want to do which I
think that stuff time yeah we have about
nine minutes left in this Pomodoro
session so what I'd like to do now is
make a github repo for this just
bare-minimum github repo I'm just gonna
change just a bit and let's say
I don't want to say mobile app you say
react news
my typing is terrible today okay remove
these and save that and now we're gonna
make a git repo out of this and then
push that up it'll be in there obviously
there's like so much we want to do this
is the bare minimum of of apps that we
could make right now
oh no I didn't have my screen on I'm
really bad at that and having my screen
switched back over so y'all can see what
I'm doing okay
so what we need to do first is a get in
it alright so we are in the folder right
our project folder we're gonna do a git
init let's see okay great
get commit let me make sure I have a
getting more file yes I do
awesome I thought it came automatically
but I just wanted to be sure so we're
gonna get commits
and it's get in it and so I come it's
and
there we go so after my silliness there
I had to add the files first before I
could commit them obviously sorry about
that okay now we have our repository
let's go ahead and create a repository
and get up and then link the two up and
then we can push what we have so far up
to github and then that way if anybody
wants to take a look at it or mess with
it or anything then then you'll have
that let's see get home and we're gonna
create a new repository we're gonna do
it under the fus Markham organization
and we're gonna call this our C native
make that public and I don't want to add
anything right now we can add in our
license and we already have a GUID
ignore we can add in the readme later
actually we already have a readme we
just have to edit it so let's create
okay
so now we already have a repository so
we're just gonna copy each of these
lines I never tried copying both of the
lines at once would that work I guess it
would but in this one we're gonna whoops
you all probably can't see that uh there
we go
we're gonna add right this is our like
SSH address for our repo so we're going
to add that and then our next one we're
gonna actually push to the repo that
we've just linked to
great now we should be able to see that
code that we just had yep so here we go
here's uh there we go there's our code
and there's our text that we edited all
right so that's that's ready to go so
now we have a repo to work out of like I
said earlier I'm not gonna be working
primarily on this or any of our other
electron or native things that we're
gonna do because that's not that's not a
priority right now for me it's just
something that will be helpful and that
I really like to work on but I will keep
up with a pull request or at least I'll
do my best to keep up with them and I'll
bring them up from time to time you know
if things change and if we do work on
some of these things all right and -
cycle yeah and plumb to our cycles
almost over so I'm gonna go back to the
live chat I'm gonna answer any questions
that you all have and now after I get to
the bottom a live chat we'll finish up
the stream for today
well okay O'Neill said I could also
check out if they're efficient new
version of Expo that's a good idea I
mean we got it to work but that's still
a good idea to make sure everything is
is up to date
John Hanson says looks easy Yeah right
yes it looks familiar what is the
trigger or logic to call the app to
render on a device as opposed to that's
a desktop create react app it should be
it's it's the same so essentially in
terms of what's going on in the
background I have no idea right
it's and it's working differently
depending on if it's a OS or Android but
in terms of you know as a developer or
what we have to do the triggering in the
render works the same way everything is
controlled by the state
right so you you never just like in
normal react you never manipulate
manipulate the Dom directly it's the
same thing here even though we don't
even have a Dom you change the state and
then things are you know here in the
state so just for instance let's just
say
it's
so you do this and I can't believe I'm
losing my mind where do I put state up
here right so our state is going to be
display display text it's false we're
gonna say it's false right now
oops not that state X is false and so we
would do something like this right
display text it was my
hopefully this is answering your
question and I'm not like totally
missing the point here
okay so if we save that ID I'll get an
error can't find whoops sorry state this
state display text
okay so our state is false and let's see
if I can open debug jazz remotely let's
try to open up this remote debugger and
I have no idea where this is gonna open
up at too many screens open and I can't
find the debugger there it is
all right so let's inspect and let's
just pop this out and make it bigger
here's our debugger oh goodness
alright let's go to our react oh no do
we not even do not have the reactive
bugger well this is not this is not good
what do I not have the reacting bugger
oh well I can't do what I wanted to do
all right let's get rid of that we'll
just add something nice thing all right
so let's do is that how it is I think
that's what it is in react native
it's a H
this set state and then we'll just do
display text true so I have to do
Street you haven't coded anything for a
week and now I'm like forgetting
everything all right this is saved see
[ __ ] there
alright not working
all right so I'm I'm not gonna try to
work with this anymore because obviously
I'm I'm forgetting too much it has been
over a month since I did anything with
react native so I'm messing something up
but I guess I can just do this just to
even see if my code is correct at all
there we go so we can see the state is
true really small there so you could
probably see that we have two lines you
can't really read it but anyway sorry I
just went through all that and I
couldn't get it to work I'm guessing
that my issue is I I don't know what
what the right handler is here I don't
think you can do it on click because
you're not clicking but I can't remember
what what you're supposed to do
I'm healed says you can set up an
Android simulator on your window or
iPhone simulator on iOS to work with
Expo yes so I that's true so I don't
have it set up you can actually set up
the Android thing on iOS too but last
time I checked it was just more
complicated than I wanted to do since I
already have an Android device it's
easier just to run it on there I tried
to get the simulator to come up but I
got an error so I just didn't really
feel like trying to fix it you know on
the stream but if we do start working
with it a lot on the stream I'll make
sure I get the simulator at very least
for iOS up and running alright so native
w01
says jesse have you tried the new
version of firefox it's called firefox
quantum and it's pretty dang good just
made the switch from chromium or from
chrome today I have not tried it yet but
I've heard really good things about it
so I may have to try that soon as anyone
else used it like I everybody's saying
it's super fast I know says are you
gonna create some issues I will create
some issues I'll do my best to create
them soon let me think what I have I
gotta think about what else I need to do
that like needs done right now if so if
I have time today maybe I'll try to do
some issues otherwise I'll try to get
them in there sometime soon
Blake says I use SSH to pool repo once
and every minute it would ask me for my
SSH password well I was working on it
I'm trying to think how I set it up you
should be able to set it up so that you
don't you don't need to it won't ask you
if your SSH password
actually you know what I do see if this
works
are so Blake the next time you use SSH
to pull Revo do this and see if it works
yeah so do SSH ad so SSH - ad hit enter
it'll ask for your passphrase and then
enter it in there and then you should
need to enter it in again I don't have
to enter in again until I restart my
computer which is infrequently so Elvis
once you do that as long as you don't
restart things then you won't need to
put in your password again
Alex B says Jesse I'm new to free code
camp I saw you did a lot of videos with
multiple technologies can you recommend
me playlists the series to start from I
guess at this point it does depend a
little bit about what you're interested
in but most of our projects have used
react so it might maybe you want to
start with project 5 day 1 and because
it would be really easy for you to catch
up because we're not that far into the
project if you're not worried about
catching up with the live stream then I
would go with maybe project 3 or 4
trying to think what was projects maybe
project 4 then because those are kind of
simple to get start out with we're using
create react app you start with one of
those I don't recommend starting with
project 1 anymore because it's already
kind of out of date we started that
months ago there already we use next
there are already new versions of next
and we use jQuery with with react which
I don't recommend doing so yeah so start
with you can start with really any of
the projects but I would not recommend
starting with project 1 Project 5 is the
best if you want to catch up to the live
stream quickly
okay Michael is saying you should use
touchable opacity and on press okay
let's let's try that
[Music]
let's do that
oh cool let me try this
it sure is
oops I might have to put text
for some of the buttons in react native
you have to put text inside and for some
of them you don't I can't remember what
you once you do and don't so yep I think
that was it
great all right cool so let me reload
this and just show you my camera okay
all right so this is gonna be really
small so right now I know it's hard to
say but if you have our click Me button
there it's just text and if I click it
now we have the more text right the
state is true so in terms of like
rendering telling it Linda render it's
exactly the same right we just have the
equivalent of an on click Handler and
that does not directly do anything to
anything that's on the screen but what
it does do is it changes a state every
time there's a state change that
triggers the rerender so that's that's
still how we're how we're handling
things thanks again Michael for setting
me straight on how I needed to do that
Blake says the new version of Firefox is
good but I just prefer chrome John says
the new Firefox is good but just a day
after chrome really pumped up their dev
tools sticking with Chrome here yeah
that's what I'm wondering my big
question with the new Firefox is how are
the dev tools because I like Chrome's
dev tools so for me it doesn't really
matter how fast Firefox is if Chrome has
better dev tools I'm sticking with
Chrome at least for death if I'm just
looking on the internet for something
else
then I'll go with Firefox but actually
to be also if I'm just browsing online
I'm using my phone if I'm on a laptop or
desktop I'm most likely working so I'm
still gonna try it obviously but that's
going to be the deciding factor for me
is the dev tools okay
so that's the end of the live chat and
no more questions or comments so it's we
actually ended up getting more coding
done than I thought we would so a lot of
new exciting things happening and I'll
be setting up some more repos and
hopefully adding some more issues to
those repos so whether you're interested
in regular react react with Gatsby react
with next create react app react native
or using react with electron there will
be something for you to learn from and
contribute to so I'm really excited
about that it feels like we're we're
covering like all the react areas now we
just need something with Redux I think
and then we'll really be like hitting
all the major things but those will all
be available we'll be talking about all
those in the in the coming month and our
main project is still going to be
project 5 so that'll get the most
attention but we are going to branch out
a bit and this will be cool I hope we
have some more people you know
contributing to the code and
helping helping you to learn and build
up your portfolio's alright so I will
stream tomorrow I'm gonna I'm gonna try
my best to stream tomorrow I may have to
attend a three hour long training
session on leadership I would rather not
but it's not up to me so that's going to
take out a big chunk of my day I'll let
you know if and when I can stream on
Twitter tomorrow and of course I will
schedule the stream so you should get a
notification if you're subscribed to the
free code camp channel just in case I
don't stream if you still want to see me
you can check out on my channel my
personal channel which is linked in the
description I believe you can check out
my talk from November that I just gave
on Tuesday afternoon about live
streaming and live coding so so you can
still watch me somewhat live uh-huh if
you SS that that was like a shameless
plug wasn't it but anyway you guys might
like it or you all might like it because
I talked about you in a very good way in
my my talk from November so check that
out if you get a minute it's only 30
minutes long a little less than 30
minutes
alright so until then like I said
hopefully I see you all tomorrow I
really really hope I can cuz I haven't
seen for a while and I miss it but if
not I guess I'll see you CEO on Monday
but either way have a great day and I
will be back soon